- Police is coming by the way.
Just FYI.
There's an accident.
Fuck, there's an
accident, fucked us.
Oh, that was a cop itself.
I would've followed that
black car back in the day.
Good thing I'm
not driving any more.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
- [Woman] Cities
like New York, Hartford,
and Providence are all
expecting to get between
12 to 18 inches of snow.
Boston and Philadelphia could
see up to a foot and some other
areas could get
more than two feet.
- [Gary] Andy K.
Morning, Brit.
Morning.
Nobody's going
anywhere any more.
There's not a
flight out of New York.
Yeah, it's smart.
Fast.
You don't get the
benefits unless you move.
("FF" by Sonder)
- [Tyler] Got a
blizzard coming in.
Switch up some flights.
Jordan's flight got canceled.
DRock's who knows where
in this country right now.
Working through some kind of
high level structural so that is
big, that helps.
A lot of times we get stuck
in the day-to-day calendar and
there's a lot of meetings that
don't allow us to quickly make
macro two hours with
the leadership team happen.
Because in order to do that,
that's canceling if we got eight
15-minute meetings or
something like that,
we're kind of
letting those people down.
So when something
like this comes in,
blizzard, he's flying to
SF with our CFO,
it was decided in 10 minutes.
Booked the flights.
We actually got the last two
first class flights out
of New York City tonight.
Booked a hotel, he's gonna spend
five hours tomorrow with the CFO
all on the (inaudible) and he
was supposed to be in Austin so
within four days
he was in Austin,
then he was in
New York, still got a full day
in New York which was fantastic.
But then that all
got canceled now.
That's even more fantastic.
In between those
times this came about.
Now he's flying
to SF with our CFO,
spend the whole day together.
Catch up on some
sleep and then from there
he speaks in SF Wednesday.
Speaks in
Salt Lake City Thursday.
Flies back, full
day in New York Friday.
Goes to Vancouver
Saturday, speaks in Vancouver.
Flies home then is
doing a week with family.
So lot of logistical stuff and
just getting
better at it which helps.
There's also anxiety when you
first start
booking a lot of flights.
It's funny, growing up you think
about booking a flight and going
on a vacation with your family.
It's like this
big process of okay,
we're gonna book the flights.
Now I book flights in my sleep
and so that anxiety of hitting
buy has gone away
and that's a big deal.
So I can quickly,
just boom, boom, boom.
Yeah, that's that.
- I think you just, you
know, you're a young dude.
How old are you?
- [Man] 28.
- Yeah, I mean I think
it's gonna ebb and flow.
If this place is going to be the
continuing rocket ship that is
there may be some real
opportunities for you and/or
I think that you get to
a place where you're like,
"Fuck man, I just need
to do shit for myself."
Here's the good news.
This office is open for you if
you want to grow here or if you
want support or strategy
to win outside of here.
I think there is no advice.
It's hard to balance both.
- [Man] Right.
- You got a reverse
engineer your mindset
of like where you're at.
And your world's gonna change.
So many thing
happen between 28 and 35
in a man and woman's life.
I think you need to
just think about how
you want it to
play out. You know?
There's no wrong or right.
You got plenty of time.
- [Man] Mhmmm.
- Things will change.
Do you want to have a family?
Where do you want to live?
These are things that
really start to manifest.
I think the one, I will give
you one big piece of advice.
I do think the economy
can't stay great forever.
- [Man] Right.
- And I do think that that's
something you have to factor in
if you're gonna
with more high risk
and do it all by
yourself or reverse.
I mean I don't know, Vayner's
gonna do better that others but
the amount of agency people that
are gonna be looking for jobs in
two or three years
when shit hits the fan.
I don't know.
The good news is you can come
and have any
conversation with me.
Good.
Anything I can answer for you?
- I'm sure you get asked all
types of interesting questions.
- You know, I just want to
answer the questions people
have, you know?
- Yeah.
- I'm not looking
for something clever.
I'm looking for
truths. You know?
- Me and my friends have been
kind of talking about this a lot
is we are in our mid-20s,
starting to evaluate our
passions and the validity of
our paths and it's this question
what is it that
makes you forget to shit?
- [Gary] Being a businessman.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Gary] Like I've got it.
- [Gary] I've always had it.
Like running my businesses.
I don't even eat.
Can't shit if you didn't eat.
- [Man] Yeah. (laughs)
- [Gary] Do you
know what I mean?
- [Man] Absolutely.
- [Gary] So I got it real good.
That's what stops me
from going to the bathroom.
The game.
- [Man] Yeah.
- You know it's crazy,
I do the vlog but it's edited.
- [Man] Right.
- People are like well you never
eat or anything and then people
will leave comments like
but it's the way it's edited.
But Tyler and
DRock know I don't.
- [Man] Yeah.
- I'm a robot
because I'm so passionate.
- [Man] Yeah.
- My work. My work.
- [Man] That's awesome.
- You know, that's
what I wish for everybody.
("Sheath" by Sonder)
Ready?
- Yeah.
- Ready? I got
to just go, sorry.
- Three, two, one, go.
- Actually this is a
pretty impressive resume but
do you have any degrees?
- Yeah, actually
I have two of them.
- Two degrees, huh?
You're hired.
My pleasure, real pleasure.
Alright, let's walk.
("Sheath" by Sonder)
Want me to do YouTube
live for this episode?
We have wifi.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we should, right?
'Cause we have
wifi it'll go hard.
Here you go, Sean.
You can flip it around.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 244 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey Taylor, it's GaryVee.
You're on The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Taylor] No way!
- Yes way.
- [Taylor] Holy crap. Okay.
How do you get over the
stump of you're graduating,
and you feel all this pressure
'cause you're trying to build
something but
you're still so young.
But you wanna do the
stuff and grow it big.
I'm just in a rut.
- You need to be
patient as fuck, Taylor.
You're 22, 23-years-old.
Like what do you
think's gonna happen overnight?
- [Taylor] Yeah, I know.
- You need to be fast.
7 A.M. to two in
the morning every day.
But in the big picture, you need
to realize nothing good is gonna
happen for the next six years.
Every second you spend thinking
about what somebody else has is
taking away from
time that you could
create something for yourself.
("One Unread" by Sonder)
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- You're losing.
You're losing 'cause you're
laying in your bed looking at
somebody's fucking glamorous
photoshopped picture of them
doing something cool.
You're envious,
and you're jealous,
and you're impatient, and
it's crippling your upside.
- [Taylor] Yeah 'cause
that's where I wanna be
and I know I'm not there yet.
- [Gary] You haven't done shit.
- [Taylor] I know.
- [Gary] So go do shit that
actually gets you there so that
you earn it instead of like you
dwelling that you're not there
and hoping that's
something's gonna happen.
I don't know what's
going through your mind.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
Well I guess I'm hustling on
the side but I don't think
I'm doing enough I guess.
- [Gary] You've gotta
deploy patience and
you gotta love the process.
I'm addicted to the
process of the battle scars,
the setbacks.
You need to stop giving a shit
about what anybody else has and
realize that if you put your
head down and just work for the
next 10 years, no glamour,
no new fucking car,
suitcase, jewelry,
trip, event, no Coachella,
no fucking new fucking sneakers.
Like fuckin' work,
you will have it.
Every time you care about one
of the things I just mentioned,
it will slow down
your process of having it.
Work.
That's the answer
to all these questions.
- [Taylor] Got it.
- Work, learn things,
do stuff, try to sell shit,
learn how to make money.
Work.
- [Taylor] Alright, I will.
- I'm gonna give you the
best piece of advice I got.
- Alright, I have pen.
- Knock yourself out, it's not
super complicated but I think
it's actually right.
- Mhmmm.
- You need to,
more than anything,
think about two core
things in my opinion.
And this is all
through very little context,
we need to get to
know each other better.
- Yeah.
- One, you have to
at all costs not beat
your own self up with yourself.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] At all costs.
- [Woman 2] Fair enough.
- [Gary] It's huge.
- [Woman 2] It's huge
and it's hard to do. (laughs)
- [Gary] Correct.
It's huge.
- [Woman 2] Yeah.
- [Gary] You need to really be
your own biggest fan instead of
critiquing everything.
Yeah, send him in.
- [Tyler] (inaudible)You should
go downstairs in 10 minutes.
- [Gary] I need to see Roger.
- [Tyler] Okay.
- [Gary] I need
to bang them all out.
- [Tyler] At the risk
of you missing this flight?
- What time's the flight?
- [Tyler] It's at 7:55 but it
can take you an hour and a half
to get over there and it's
just gonna be madness having you
clear through...
- This is fucking insane.
This dude is so talented. Right?
We need to hang this.
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- Best painting ever.
My man, Franco, appreciate it.
Look at the blue eyes.
Look at Joe Namath's blue eyes.
("One Unread" by Sonder)
- [Woman] Yeah, yeah.
- [Gary] It's huge.
- [Woman] Or comparing
yourself to other people.
- [Gary] Yes because you don't
know their truth by the way.
- [Woman] You're right.
- [Gary] You don't
know what's under the hood.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- [Gary] It looks the part.
People could tell you at the
fucking Zachy's wine tasting
on Saturday in
Scarsdale but it's not true.
Do you understand?
- [Woman 2] Absolutely.
- [Gary] It's important.
- [Woman 2] But it's also--
- Number two,
this one, of course.
Number two, moments in time.
- [Woman 2] Mhmmm.
- You got to wrap your head
around how young you actually
are which seems
insanely different
when you have
kids and duh, duh, duh.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- [Gary] You have to wrap your
head around how early in the
process this is and how this
is just a very
small moment in time.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- How we build the social
following and how we see it and
people from my team and I think
both would be smart depending on
how this fleshes out after
whether you know you're not
doing anything with a business
partner in the short term or
whether you are and how
does that incorporate to that.
Very quickly I can tell you you
need to get every voice out of
your head besides yourself
and you need to love yourself.
You will win.
No, you will.
If you just accept
yourself, like fuck man.
Do you know how
many shortcomings I have?
But it doesn't feel like that
if you're consuming my content
because I don't
have any time for it.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- Like, what?
You gonna beat yourself up?
Can't live your life based on
other people's point of view.
What's it saying on timing?
- [Avi] 7:14.
- [Gary] No!
- [Avi] Yeah.
- Holy shit, we're
gonna miss this flight
and if we do we're finished.
- [Alan] We're fucked.
- Oh fuck.
7:14?
(blows raspberry)
That's really bad man.
That's really fuckin' bad.
- What is it, 7:55?
- Fuck man.
We're in deep shit.
Police is coming by the way.
Just FYI.
There's an accident.
Fuck, there's an
accident, fucked us.
Oh, that was a cop itself.
I would've followed that
black car back in the day.
Good thing I'm
not driving any more.
Avi, what's the number now?
- [Avi] 7:15 still.
We're gonna re-route it so
we're gonna get off
here take surface streets.
- [Gary] There must've
been a huge accident, huh?
What's it say now?
Bye.
Thank you man, bye-bye.
Pumped about that, pissed I'm
gonna miss this flight
and I'm gonna lose out
$150,000 in speaking.
It closes at 7:45.
- [Avi] 7:26.
- [Gary] Yeah, it's over.
- [Alan] 7:26?
- [Gary] What time's the flight.
- [Alan] 7:55.
- [Gary] You need to eliminate
at all costs everybody else's
voices and
everything starts clicking.
You need to
remember this conversation
because it's easy
and it feels good right now
but then a few weeks
from now it goes away.
This is real shit.
This is how you get happy.
("Laura" by Wolff)